bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france pour d'abord pour
recontextualiser il ya quand même depuis
plusieurs semaines donc une situation à
nouveau tendue dans le donbass l'est de
l'ukraine
des dizaines de milliers de soldats
russes ils sont déployés crève qui est
craint une opération armée la russie
affirme de son côté que personne ne doit
se sentir menacé
d'abord pourquoi ces nouvelles tensions
dans la région je commence par vous jean
de gliniasty vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur de france en russie et
directeur de recherche à l'iris
bonjour mais je crois que c'est une
période de test une période de test
aussi un nouveau président américain
c'est une période de test parce que à
l'occasion de cette présidence cette
nouvelle présidence on voit que les
efforts du format normandie n'ont pas eu
beaucoup d'effet et donc on essaye de
voir si on peut pas essayer autre chose
qu elle cette plate forme de crime et
qui a été posé par les ukrainiens qui
associerait en fait au règlement de la
question en tout cas de crimes et les
américains les anglais
donc on essaye des formules il ya des
moulinets il ya des pressions de part et
d'autre il ya c'est notamment les les
manoeuvres différentes dates one et one
liquide ce qui ont été reportés à 2021
qui devrait avoir lieu même en format
plus réduit dans des manoeuvres de
l'otan et donc eh bien on montre un peu
sa force mais je ne crois pas que
personne n'est là l'intention d'en
recourir aux armes
françois chauve en cire votre avis oui
bonsoir où je partage le même point de
vue à la date d'aujourd'hui un
affrontement traditionnel militaire
entre la russie et ukraine paraît peu
vraisemblable
je rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit
monsieur l'ambassadeur c'est qu'en fait
on est bien dans la gesticulation
l'affirmation de sa force sans avoir à
la montre et d'une manière physique
c'est de l'intimidation et on est un peu
d'entrain de construire
rapport de force diplomatique pour que
chacun puisse tirer positivement pour
lui les pagnes du jeu c'est ça
l'objectif nous sommes vraiment dans un
jeu diplomatique plus que militaire jean
de gliniasty la juge la russie justifie
ses manoeuvres à la frontière avec
l'ukraine en raison des agissements de
l'otan et de l'ukraine qu'elle juge
agressive
moscou qui s'interroge aussi sur les
activités de l'otan dans la région et
des états unis notamment en mer noire
que se passe-t-il concrètement du côté
de l'alliance et de l'ukraine
à ce niveau il ya déjà une bonne
nouvelle c'est que je crois comprendre
c'est les turcs qu'ils ont annoncé que
les la patrouille de deux croiseurs
américain de gros bateau américain qui
devait avoir lieu en mer noire dans ce
contexte a été reportée redirigée vers
un autre but est donc donc ça c'est
incontestablement si c'est confirmé mais
je crois que c'est le cas le résultat de
l'entretien téléphonique entre byden et
et poutine donc déjà il ya une petite
baisse de la tension qui quant au reste
c'est clair qu'il ya tout il ya souvent
eu dans le passé et des roulements de
tambours de part et d'autre avec des
manoeuvres de l'otan avec des manoeuvres
de la russie mais il faut souvenez quand
même que les manoeuvres russes ont lieu
sur le territoire russe
les manoeuvres de l'otan et ayant lieu
sur le territoire des nombres de l'otan
defender 2021 dois avouer avoir lieu
dans les pays baltes et en pologne
donc on est dans un contexte
effectivement ou montre on montre ses
muscles et chacun a quelques raisons de
de considérer que l'autre fait monter la
tension
revenons-en justement à la réunion du
jour ce qui était l'hôte des mayas le
maquereau à paris donc une
visioconférence également avec angela
merkel paris et berlin qui demande tout
simplement le retrait des troupes russes
à la frontière et créez comment vous
analysé cette médiation
on rappelle que c'est une médiation de
longue date sous format déjà normandie
avec le crâne à et la russie françois
chossy je dirais qu'on a quand même deux
est important qu'ils sont la france et
l'allemagne très préoccupé par ce qui se
passe en ukraine est aussi j'irai
peut-être dans les relations entre
l'union européenne et la russie
n'oublions pas que la russie suite à
l'invasion d'un crime est toujours sous
la menace sa phase où les sous les
sanctions notamment économiques
ce qui fait que c'est un contexte assez
particulier
maintenant que la france et l'allemagne
veulent reprendre un peu la main sur la
diplomatie
peut-être justement par rapport aux
américains qui reviennent un peu dans le
jeu je pense aussi c'est un objectif
maintenant pour revenir aux questions de
l'otan et finalement au déploiement des
forces armées c'est vrai que d'à côté on
a les russes qui font leurs manoeuvres
en russie l'autre côté les otaniens qui
font leurs manoeuvres dans la zone
d'autant mais après tout ça fait partie
aussi des entraînements traditionnel
militaire et que c'est de
l'instrumentalisation finalement des
forces militaires sur le terrain en
exercice qui inquiète maintenant
n'oublions pas que l'histoire nous a
montré que des troupes qui manoeuvrait
pas d'une fronde près d'une frontière
était capable d'envahir le pays voisin
donc on peut comprendre que certains
s'inquiètent notamment les ukrainiens
avec quelques dizaines de milliers de
soldats russes à leurs frontières
jean de gliniasty justement la france et
l'allemagne qui demande le retrait des
troupes russes d'un autre côté le
président ukrainien volodimir qui lui
demandent à nouveau sommet identique à
celui de 2019
on se dirige vers quoi vers une
désescalade réellement je pense que
l'escaladé est inévitable parce que sens
inverse
on sait pas où on s'arrête donc là des
scans a déjà commencé avec l'histoire
des bateaux maintenant la demande 2
hélène ce qu'il y en a deux en fait il
demande un sommet puis demande plus gêné
allemand un soutien pour adhérer à
l'otan sur le sommeil à un problème
c'est que les russes ont toujours
demandé que en gros on soit assurée
d'avoir des résultats concrets s'il ya
un sommet ça a été une difficulté
lorsqu'on a organisé le sommet du 9
décembre à paris c'est qu'il a fallu
genou négocié pendant très longtemps
pour que les chefs d'état et quelque
chose à se mettre sous la dent donc on
va avoir la même difficulté mais disons
que cette demande de sommeil que tout le
monde souhaite d'ailleurs elle va donner
une nouvelle impulsion à la négociation
dans le cadre du peu à troyes et dans le
cadre du pharma normandie donc on peut
espérer que ça déclenche une dynamique
positive sur le temps c'est tout à fait
autre chose parce que évidemment le la
mise en oeuvre de ce qu'on appelle en
anglais le même baci pacsés jeune
princesse c'est à dire une procédure
accélérée d'adhésion à l'otan
elle a été bloquée par madame merkel
déjà et par le président sarkozy en
avril 2008 sommet de bucarest
il n'y a aucune raison que l'attitude de
la france et de l'allemagne change sur
ce point donc de ce côté là la
déclaration pourquoi ce blocage
d'ailleurs de la france et de
l'allemagne
parce que je crois que maintenant
l'expérience géorgienne approuvé
l'adhésion à l'otan d'un pays comme
l'ukraine est un et d'un facteur au
minimum de tension supplémentaire avec
la russie et que la russie l'a fait
savoir très clairement
vous êtes d'accord françois chauvin si
oui je rajouterais comme quelque chose
c'est que permettent à l'ukraine
d'adhérer à l'otan voudrait dire que
tous les membres de l'otan s'engage à la
protéger en cale en cas d'agression
l'article 5 e notamment de l'alliance
atlantique impose la défense collective
et que le fait même que l'ukraine en
crise
pourrait-on dire comme extérieur avec la
russie puisse rejoindre l'otan et que
l'on dise oui voudrait dire que s'il y
avait une nouvelle agression contre
l'ukraine
nous serions peut-être contraint
d'intervenir donc l'adhésion à l'otan ne
pourrait se concevoir que si l'ukraine
est elle réellement en paix avec la
russie
donc ce serait nous met dans un piège
tél et puis hier on voulait pas se
battre pour dent de scie que je vois pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui on irait se battre
pour kiev
alors le dernier sommet au format
normandie en 2019 qui s'est tenu à paris
pour relancer donc le processus de paix
dans le donbass s'est tenu sur la base
quand même des accords de minx et on
sait qu'aujourd'hui la russie met en
avant ses accords de munich le respect
de ces accords dit qu'il ne faut pas
s'inquiéter de la présence de troupes de
nouvelles troupes russes à la frontière
ukrainienne et et met en avant le
respect de ces accords qu'en est-il
concrètement les accords de minsk eux
deux en fait ont été signés en février
2015 dans un contexte très particulier
c'est à dire le contexte où l'armée
ukrainienne avait été défaite par les
forces rebelles appuyés par la russie
est donc l'ukraine est en état de
faiblesse et l'ukraine a toujours estimé
que ces accords domine ce qui était déjà
fort et donc bien qu'ils réaffirment pas
ce qu'on leur demande de le faire à
chaque fois qu'un peu habituelle la
validité des accords de munich dans la
réalité les ukrainiens ne veulent pas
beaucoup parce que c'est accord implique
en fait que les provinces rebelles
soient réintégrés dans l'ukraine et pèse
sur l'évolution institutionnelle la
politique étrangère du pays
ce dont les dirigeants actuels du prêt
ne veulent en aucun cas
donc en fait il ya un problème de fond
du coup il ya une discussion entre la
russie d'un côté l'ukraine de l'autre
sur l'application des accords de minsk
chacun ayant son interprétation la
vérité oblige à dire que
l'interprétation des russes est plus
conforme à la lettre de l'accord
et pour cause puisque cet accord leur
est éminemment favorable
une des difficultés c'est par exemple à
quel moment les produits craignent elles
reviendront à la frontière officiel
entre la russie et l'ukraine dans les
accords c'est vraiment tout à la fin du
processus
alors que les les ukrainiens souhaite
que toutes les quelques clauses
militaire soit d'avoir réalisé avant de
s'engager sur l'autonomie du territoire
du donbass et de lougansk donc il y à
une divergence
vous êtes d'accord françois choisi c'est
parce que c'est vrai que la russie aussi
de demande à kiev de cesser ses
provocations
de quelle provocation par le ton la cdu
provocation sur le terrain c'est du
mouvement de troupes c des combats
sporadiques mais on est encore dans
l'instrumentalisation même si ça se
résume par des mort d'homme parce qu'il
ya eu quand même un centre de soldats
qui ont été tuées notamment ukrainien
bon maintenant je crois que la plus
grande difficulté dans cette affaire
1000 points du militaire c'est tout
simple quand même dans ce qu'on appelle
depuis quelques années une guerre
hybride une guerre hybride où finalement
on ne sait pas qui est l'ennemi et ça ne
permet pas de résoudre la situation
il ya une instrumentalisation notamment
de l'est de l'ukraine avait quand même
des russophiles avec de très bonnes
raisons d'ailleurs mais dont on parle
peu mais qui représente quelques
dizaines de milliers de combattants
il ya un refus de l'autorité centrale
nous sommes dans des guerres où
finalement effectivement la russie a et
gagnant dans cette affaire là pour
l'instant
et puis à sait pertinemment que qui va
s'opposer à elle la question est là nous
n'irons pas de battre pour l'ukraine
nous n'irons pas nous battre paul crête
en revanche ce que nous souhaitons c'est
que la paix s'installe quand même
maintenant comment faisons nous et là
j'avoue que je ne vois pas comment on va
y arriver
quand on voit la situation face à
quelqu'un qui est déterminé avec une
armée entraînée qui a fait ses preuves
qui n'hésite pas d'ailleurs à être
utilisés par rapport à un autre côté
puissance fait l'on parlait d'
effectivement la puissance ukrainienne
militaire faible avec les défaites
initiales figurant pas beaucoup de
soutien de l'étranger
comment voulez vous qu'on s'en sorte par
la défaite de l'ukraine
et c'est sa difficulté nous sommes sur
une situation de défaite deux victoires
de l'ukraine dans lesquelles les uns les
autres ou du moins du côté occidental on
ne veut pas perdre la face alors qu en
fait en train de la perdre puisque face
à nous on a quelqu'un qui est déterminé
qui a les moyens pour appuyer sa
détermination et que sur le temps long
je pense que vladimir poutine
des chances quand même d'avoir une
victoire j rep stratégique le président
russe qui prône le dialogue tout comme
son homologue américain joe biden ou
paris des états unis tout à l'heure
justement est ce que les états unis joe
biden qui prône aussi un dialogue en vue
de la situation actuelle mais est ce que
les états unis peuvent réellement jouer
un rôle compte tenu des tensions entre
les etats-unis et la russie on voit
encore notamment avec ces accusations de
cyberattaques d'ingérence dans les
dernières élections américaines de la
part de washington vis-à-vis de moscou
jean de gliniasty je crois que dans le
jir dans le scénario habituel surtout
quand tu as un nouveau président
américain arrive il commence par faire
des moulinets par 2 par dire que il est
courageux qu'il a il n'hésite pas à
critiquer ses adversaires et puis
ensuite on commence à négocier alors
bailon la fête ça sent assez peu
protocolaire certain moment puisqu'il a
qualifié poutine de tueurs mais dans la
réalité surviendra exactement même ils
ont beaucoup de choses à discuter que ça
soit le pen que ça soit l'évaluation de
l'afghanistan qui est un sujet qui
concerne la russie que ce soir le climat
que ce soit une trêve en matière de
cyber et donc ils vont commencer à
discuter
moi j'ai été très frappé par le
l'abandon du du parcours des 2 3 heures
en mer noire qui suit après le coup de
fil byden poutine alors les américains
viennent de prendre de nouvelles
sanctions dans la presse russes ont dit
que ces sanctions ne sont pas très
significative il n'en reste pas moins
que le le rouble mais tombée est très
brutalement et qu'un sommet doit avoir
lieu alors nous on ne sait pas si les
russes donc réagir aux sanctions en
annulant ou reportant le sommeil et ses
terres que toute façon ils devront se
parler ils devront se voir comme ils le
font tous et moscou cas alors c'est on
va en parler juste après moscou qu'a
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'elle allait
expulser diplomates américains françois
chossy pour conclure je dirais que pour
l'instant l'avantagé est à la russie et
que la faiblesse et du côté d'abord de
l'ukraine et aussi de ses alliés et que
nous avons une france et une allemagne
qui plus ou moins
l'union européenne cherche à faire
avancer une solution européenne
kim à mon avis aboutira peut s'il n'y a
pas de moyen de pression sur la russie
actuellement
quant aux etats-unis ont certes les deux
bateaux sont peut-être revenu et si
c'est bien la bonne raison ça ne les
empêchera pas d'envoyer des conseillers
militaires pour former l'armée
ukrainienne sur le terrain et
éventuellement d'envoyer des équipements
militaires
donc on est vraiment dans le jeu de rôle
un dragon et nos gens peut-être le jeu
de rôle avec un rapport de force qui se
créent et dont vous parlez des deux
bateaux des deux navires en mer noire
oui tout à fait merci beaucoup avoue
françoise souvent si général de brigade
et expert en géostratégie merci à vous
également jean de gliniasty en c'est
l'ambassadeur de france en russie
directeur de recherche à l'iris